dream dream dream dream dream dream the
dream dream dream it's one of my
favorite quotes I came up with it with
my uncle had an uncle named uncle shrimp
and it uncle shrimp he was a short kind
of guy you know lost his hair I liked
the age 20 so his bald-headed and he was
just so charismatic and he told me this
after I injured myself and I realized
that I wasn't gonna be a football player
and and he told me you know they never
lose sight of your dreams but he also
told me this as who I was he knew that
now was gonna be a turning point I'd
like return to the streets and followed
in the footsteps of my father or I could
dream the impossible dream right and he
also wanted me to notice as an
african-american man because you know
that fear of having a dream and that
fear of oh I can't dream that you know I
can't God never be able to do that right
you know it was important to know that
yes you can have that dream but you have
to know honestly what it's going to take
for you to achieve that dream and so
then I came up with the quote and it
goes for everybody all genders all races
you know don't be afraid to close your
eyes and dream but then you have to open
your eyes and see the reality of what
it's going to take for you to achieve
that dream and a lot of people they kind
of see whether it's musicians or
athletes or entertainers or even just
successful people but they don't
understand the the thing that it takes
for them to get to the point that
they've gotten and you know that's why
it's a very important quote to me and I
think it you know it has inspired people
and it inspires me every day I feel so
strongly that the reason I'm here is I
dreamed big dreams I dreamed the kind of
dreams that other people said would not
be possible I'm also living proof this
isn't a Hollywood movie I come literally
from the other side of the tracks if you
saw where I grew up and we took a
picture of it the neighborhood the
setting you say it's not it's impossible
that someone could come from
there and get here but it is possible
and not to sound too trite it's possible
because we still live in a country where
the entrepreneurial spirit is so alive
and so well and anyone in this country
if you dream big and surround yourself
with great people and leave your ego at
the door and share a success with others
and have a little luck along the way you
can do anything but there will be people
along the way and I remember this who
will say to you you know you're dreaming
too big it's not possible those things
just can't happen don't allow anyone
friend family acquaintances teachers
whoever it is don't allow anyone to tell
you that what you are dreaming for
yourself and your family is not possible
it is possible don't be one of those
people 20 years from now are going to be
walking around a nine-to-five job
miserable and angry and bitter because
you let your dreams get away from you
because you did not believe stronger
enough strongly enough in yourself and
what was possible don't allow that to
happen this is an unbelievable time and
I can't encourage you enough to continue
to think that things are possible and
that your dreams can come true I want to
talk about dreams for a second and in my
case literally a dream when I was in
college I was sure that I've been
admitted by a clerical error probably a
computer error and because of that I had
an irrational fear I'd be sent all on
the bus and Sergey sure knows this is
true but it turns out because of that
anxiety I woke up literally with a dream
it was kind of a strange dream it went
like
I think I could download the entire web
onto small computers that were lying
around and that would probably seem
pretty crazy to most people but I stayed
up a couple hours in the middle of the
night doing some math and it seemed
actually pretty plausible while assuming
he actually didn't keep any of the white
pages you only kept the links and then
sort of figured out given all that data
I thought I would take a couple weeks
and I told my advisor that and he just
sort of laughed to me and of course took
me a year or two but at the end of that
we had a way to rank web pages and no
thoughts to search at all eventually and
you know the rest
everybody's the business plan may not
work out the way you wrote it down there
be some deviations there'll be some
roadblocks people start over again and
again and again on new ideas but the
person who stays focused on his idea on
his dream realizes history I always had
a dream and my dream was to be banking
in business and I always always believed
that it doesn't matter where you're from
it doesn't matter what background you
have it doesn't matter education you
know you've got to try your best but my
situation I it wasn't for me so I left
school at 15 with a dream and I always
always think big you should always think
big in life never ever think that you
can't make it because others out there
are better than you you're just as good
as anyone else I said the mr. 4k is the
goal and what
it takes to get there I would do
so I was doing the daily work cleaning
the guns and going through the shooting
range
marching 20 miles a day and rolling
around up hills with weapons running at
5:00 in the morning with heavy combat
boots and all of this stuff and then
everyone just almost drops dead at night
he's totally exhausted I worked out
three hours and got up early in the
morning again to do my sit-ups and
push-ups and machine ups there was a
clear conflict the dilemma because the
lifting was not a traditional sport for
them they didn't like the idea they
didn't even have the equipment I had to
go and figure out every way possible the
two dips between chairs or to the bar
across two chairs and to upset down
rowing everyone would say this is the
wrong direction that I'm going or I'm in
a dream world and I'm useless whatever
it was I said I'm gonna break through
that no matter what it takes
I needed to reach that core that vision
that I had of being a world champion
don't ever let somebody tell you you
can't do something
not even me
all right
you got a dream
you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can do it
you want something go get it period well
as I mentioned I have this I saw this
Norwegian movie when I was about five
years old about this guy who built a
really interesting sports car I remember
saying to myself that when I grew up
that's what I want to do as well I want
to build my own car cars and sell them
and so on that dream never left me so
when I was 19 I started my first company
which was the trading campaign to make a
little bit money with the ambition to
use that money to build my own cars and
I was when I was 22 I had made little
bit of money and then I started the car
company and that was in 1994 18 years
ago
it's hard changing your life it was hard
when just over three years ago in the
Penobscot building in Detroit Michigan
where I was operating my business and I
fell on some hard times and I was
sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment
and I said yes and I walked up to the
counter and he gave me an envelope and
he said would you mind reading it here
and I opened the envelope and the
envelope was from management that says
this is an office tower it's not a hotel
please do not sleep in your office and I
said excuse me sir I said I just worked
long hours and creating my business I'm
an entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor him and two
other dreamers up there look at him it
was hard ladies and gentlemen coming to
speak to people
and I was facing financial difficulties
in my own life I was behind on my bills
and my dreams and I'm saying to them you
can live your dream it was hard ladies
and gentlemen it was very difficult to
pick myself up each day believing that I
can do it there were times that I
doubted myself and said God why why is
this happening to me I'm just trying to
take care of my children and my mother
I'm not trying to steal a Rob from
anybody how did this have to happen to
me it was very hard and here's what I
want to say to you for those of you that
have experienced some hardships don't
give up on your dream no one could have
convinced me by holding on by continuing
to push forward by continuing to run
toward my dream that one day I would
have my own talk show it's a long shot
ladies and gentlemen from Liberty City
an abandoned building auto flaw never
annoying my mother or father it's a long
shot being here with you today in this
dome in Atlanta it's a long shot no
college training labeled educable
mentally [ __ ] but I kept running
toward my dream
goes down
goats down
don't stop running to watch your dream
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this video I'd love to
know which of the 10 entrepreneurs that
you saw here today whose message meant
the most to you and it also loved to
know what your dreams are leave it in
the comments below I'm going to join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon